Welcome to the debate.
Imagine standing in the freezing cold shivering and just trying to warm yourself by repeating the word fire over and over again.
I mean, that sounds completely absurd.
It does, yeah.
But according to a profoundly challenging medieval text we are exploring today, that is exactly what most of us are doing when we talk about the divine.
The text is called The Master and the Disciple, written by a brilliant medieval author.
And we are focusing on a very specific, deeply unsettling teaching from it.
The text proposes that the school's standard creed about the Creator's unity does not actually grasp the reality the words point to.
Yeah, it's a huge claim.
Exactly.
So to frame our entire exchange, I will state the central thesis of the Master in this text verbatim.
names and descriptions are of no benefit without their essential realities.
Very powerful.
I will be representing the perspective of the master, arguing that reciting theological words without accessing the reality they point to leaves a community with absolutely nothing.
And I will be representing the perspective of the disciple.
I am defending the utility of shared vocabulary, of creed, and of the theological structures we use to understand the divine.
Which makes sense.
It is how human institutions generally operate.
Yeah, from the disciple's view, having a correct, transmissible doctrine is the absolute core requirement of faith.
We need words to package doctrine so it can be preserved, taught to our children, and understood across generations.
So how does the disciple articulate this core requirement initially?
Well, the disciple begins from a moment of crisis.
Though he initially views it as a moment of absolute confidence.
He recites A precise four-line creed to summarize his entire theological universe.
Let's hear it.
He states that the Creator is one, is just, commands by giving a choice, and forbids by giving warning.
From the disciples' perspective, the conversation should just end right there.
He thinks he solved it.
Exactly.
This is a complete and sufficient theological structure to him.
The words package the doctrine perfectly.
By memorizing those four lines, the disciple believes he has adequately comprehended the nature of the Creator.
I see why you think that, but let me give you a different perspective.
The master entirely refuses this shared vocabulary.
Really?
Completely refuses it.
Completely.
He argues that knowing the textbook definition of monotheism, what the school calls tawhid, is not the same as knowing the reality.
The master deploys a very specific analogy to explain this failure.
Think of fire and food.
If you say the word fire, that vocalization alone cooks no food.
It brightens no darkness.
A community that possesses only the word fire without actual access to combustion and heat is just a community standing in the cold, shivering while repeating A syllable.
That is a stark image.
It is.
And the master looks at the disciples' four-line creed and sees the exact same phenomenon.
The community can chant the words, they can memorize the definitions, but if they do not access the reality those words point to, they have nothing at all.
I come at it from a different way, though.
We have to look closely at the intellectual labor the school has invested in that vocabulary.
The school has produced rigorous, generation-spanning scholarship on the divine name.
Scholars have labored immensely over the exact structure, the visible form of the letters, the precise definitions.
They certainly have spent a lot of time on it.
Yeah, and they have not done this frivolously.
They have done this because words and letters are the precise instruments of human cognition.
The forms of letters themselves are the instruments human beings use to relate to the divine.
Well, I am not convinced by that line of reasoning.
because the Master applies immense pressure to exactly that defense.
He asks the disciple to look at the four letters of the name Allah.
Okay, looking at the letters.
The Master asks a devastatingly literal question.
Which of those 4 letters is the Creator?
Are you suggesting the first letter holds the reality or the last?
Well, obviously neither in isolation.
But if they are separated, which one is the divine?
If they are joined together in a specific configuration, which exact configuration holds the essential reality?
The Master's point is that the letters must be signs pointing outward.
They cannot be containers holding the reality inside them.
I'm sorry, but I just don't buy that.
Let me tell you why.
That sounds like word play.
Word play.
Yes.
Pressing on the physical forms of individual letters feels like a rhetorical trick to confuse the disciple.
If the creed is correct as a conceptual framework, why does saying the creator is one not count?
Because the word is not the reality.
But the disciple is not claiming the ink on the page is the creator.
He is claiming the concept conveyed by the word one is accurate and necessary.
Why dismiss the entire framework just because the letters are merely physical signs?
Trick, and it is not mere wordplay.
The master is exposing A fundamental error in how the disciples' school operates.
Which is what, exactly?
That the grammar of the name does not correspond to the divine reality it points to.
The master is pointing out that the school has become obsessed with the signs and has totally forgotten what the signs are for.
I see.
Ritual form, textbook definitions, and grammatical perfection have completely displaced the actual reality.
When they argue endlessly over the pronunciation of a syllable, they are studying the physical shape of the letters themselves while freezing to death.
Even if we accept the limitation of letters, the disciple is a careful thinker who has a fallback position.
The manufacture argument, yes.
Exactly.
The disciple pivots to the manufacture argument.
This is an incredibly careful, honest, and ubiquitous theological move.
The disciple argues that every made thing has a maker.
A classic sequence.
When we observe the immense order of the universe, the precision of celestial bodies, the complexity of biological life, that physical order must logically point to a creator.
We do not need the letters to contain the divine because the manufactured universe itself serves as the physical evidence.
But the master deconstructs this logical assumption with absolute precision.
He issues a non-bodily correction to this idea of the maker.
How does he do that?
He uses another specific analogy to demonstrate why this fails.
Think of the craftsman and his thing.
A worldly craftsman makes things from a pre-existing substance.
Like a carpenter needing wood.
Precisely.
A carpenter needs wood, a smith needs iron.
The act of manufacturing is essentially the act of rearranging materials that already exist.
but the creator creates from absolutely no substance.
Therefore, the craftsman model never applied in the 1st place.
You cannot extrapolate the nature of the creator by observing how a craftsman manipulates existing materials.
The fundamental act of creation from nothing shares no mechanics whatsoever with the act of manufacturing from something.
That is a severe restriction on human reasoning though.
It is meant to be.
The disciple uses the craftsman argument because it is the most logical cognitive sequence available to the human mind.
If you discard it because of the issue of pre-existing substance, you strip the disciple of the ability to infer anything at all about the creator from the created world.
That is exactly the master's intention.
Because the craftsman argument is actually dangerous.
Arguing from made things to a maker inevitably forges a hidden likeness.
The hidden likeness?
Yes.
When the human mind uses the craftsman model, it cannot help but imagine a being with a location, a geometry, and a method of physical manipulation.
Even when the school tries to protect itself by using the popular formula, nothing like his image, it secretly smuggles an image back under the table.
By using the word image.
Correct.
The very use of the word image, even in a negative context, forces the human mind to consider a geometry, a boundary.
To correct this, the master notes that the text of the Quran explicitly states, there is none like him.
No exceptions.
That is a refusal of similitude in a single clause.
It leaves no noun to which a comparison could be salvaged.
And this brings us back to the central spine of the Master's instruction.
Names and descriptions are of no benefit without their essential realities.
How is this different from any negative theology that just denies attributes?
If we strip away the craftsman model, how do we speak about the divine at all?
It is a profound problem.
Yeah, if every attempt to describe the creator is a smuggled likeness, we are left entirely mute.
The disciples framework at least gave a community a method to speak and gather.
If we dismantle that, we are dismantling the very structure of theological education.
That is an interesting point, though I would frame it differently.
The master would argue that dismantling a false structure is the strict prerequisite for encountering reality.
So where do we go from there?
To address exactly how we speak about the divine, the master relies on the profound wisdom of the commander of the faithful, peace be upon him, in the book, The Peak of Eloquence.
Okay, what is the instruction?
The instruction provided there is incredibly precise.
Attaching attributes limits and numbers the divine.
Every single attribute bears witness that it is other than the thing described.
I need you to explain the mechanics of that.
What does it mean that an attribute numbers the divine?
Let us look at the mechanics of human language.
If I say a leader is wise, I am just acknowledging their qualities, right?
I mean, acknowledging what they are.
How does attaching an attribute divide the subject?
Well, if you say the creator is powerful, you have immediately created a duality in your mind.
You have the essence of the creator and you have the distinct concept of power attached to it.
Oh, I see.
Two separate things.
Exactly.
Are the essence and the power the exact same thing?
If they are the exact same thing, the word power is redundant.
If they are not the exact same thing, you have turned absolute unity into a pairing.
You have two distinct realities.
So you divide the unity.
Yes.
As the commander of the faithful explains in that sermon,
Whoever attaches attributes pairs the divine.
Whoever pairs the divine divides the divine.
And whoever divides the divine limits and numbers the divine.
Because the intellect slices reality into pieces.
You hit the nail on the head.
The human intellect uses attributes to slice reality into comprehensible pieces.
But the creator cannot be sliced, contrasted, or numbered.
Therefore, the intellect's standard method of operation completely fails.
That's A compelling argument, but have you considered the psychological and communal cost of this position?
It is definitely a high cost.
Yeah, if we cannot point, cannot describe, cannot attach attributes without dividing the absolute unity, aren't we leaving the intellect completely bewildered and paralyzed?
You are asking the disciple to abandon the tools of reason and language.
The master introduces a final analogy to explain why this paralysis is actually the correct and necessary state of the intellect.
Think of the sun and the eye.
Okay, the sun and the eye.
The human eye is a remarkable physical instrument designed to perceive the physical world by detecting differences in light, shadows and boundaries.
but the eye cannot bear even the lesser light of the sun without breaking down.
It gets overwhelmed.
Completely.
If you stare directly at the sun, an absolute source of light, the physical instrument of your vision is destroyed.
Consequently, the intellect cannot weigh the one.
The faculties of the human mind have a strict absolute limit.
So the intellect is like the eye.
Yes, the intellect is an instrument designed to parse boundaries and differences.
When you apply an instrument designed for boundaries to an entity that has absolutely no boundaries, the instrument physically and conceptually breaks down.
So the bewilderment is natural.
It is exactly like the retina breaking down when it tries to process the sun.
It is not a failure of the seeker's devotion.
It is a structural, mechanical limitation of the cognitive instrument itself.
That is an incredibly heavy realization.
It changes everything.
The disciple has spent a lifetime building a theological vocabulary, assuming those
words were valid instruments for reaching the divine.
Now the master is demonstrating that the words are empty letters.
The craftsman model is a hidden idol.
The master systematically invalidates every logical sequence the disciple tries to use.
I have to admit, looking at it through the disciple's perspective is exhausting.
I see the absolute exhaustion of the intellectual frameworks I have defended.
The physical signs of the letters cannot contain the reality.
No, they cannot.
And the craftsman model falsely assumes pre-existing material.
The attributes inevitably divide in number what must remain absolute unity.
Given all of this mechanical failure of human cognition, I must offer the disciples concession.
Which is.
My words have left me.
I confess that intellects are bewildered and imaginations cannot reach the Creator.
I acknowledge that the names have been emptied of the function they were being used for.
The creed I recited with such confidence at the beginning is just a collection of syllables.
The Master validates this exact bewilderment.
This paralysis of the intellect is not a failure.
It is the honest, factual destination of the seeker.
To just stand in that bewilderment.
Yes, realizing that your words and your logical analogies have structurally failed is the first moment of actual truth.
You have stopped mistaking the word fire for the heat itself.
You have accepted the mechanical limits of the human cognitive instrument.
The resulting silence is daunting, though.
For a community that relies on discourse, admitting that our descriptions literally cannot reach the reality forces a complete reevaluation of practice.
It demands immense humility, and it shifts the burden of proof from reciting the right syllables to examining our actual state.
We must close by turning the stakes directly to the listener with a heavy question.
What is the question?
Which creed words am I reciting while having lost the reality behind them?
And what would it cost this week to stop?
This brings us to our final reflection, landing our central thesis one last time verbatim.
Names and descriptions are of no benefit without their essential realities.
It leaves us contemplating the silence that follows when the names are finally set down.
and recognizing the structural limits of our own minds.
Indeed, we leave you with that thought to sit in the cold and ask whether you possess the fire or merely the word.